The seemingly endless bayous of southern
Louisiana, thousands of square miles of
marshlands, home to gators, birds and not
much else.
This area could not be more inhospitable.
This is not a place that is inclined toward
sustaining human life.
Yet. Despite this, a satellite image taken on
January ten, 2019 has uncovered mysterious
evidence of human activity in these swamps.
Looking at the image, I'm seeing two
different structures here.
To the right, there's sort of a string.
Of boxes or blocks.
The other structure is really unusual and
kind of surprising.
It looks like the top of a.
Rook, like a giant chess piece in the water.
It's unnerving to think about what's missing
from this picture.
There could be an entire town under the
water.
What happened here?
What's drawn, Martin Morgan, to this site is
that officially there has never been a town
in these marshlands.
But clues suggest otherwise.
That's not natural.
You can totally tell it's a road.
Look at that. This is a bit eerie.
The abandoned road leads Morgan to the set of
structures at the eastern side of the river
mouth.
It's just up ahead here.
This thing is incredible.
It's even bigger than it looked in the
satellite photography.
A line of concrete ruins stretches for some
300 yards along the shore.
Behind them are concealed, hundreds of poles
driven deep into the lakebed.
This was a massive facility.
Somebody with money, lots of it paid to have
this built.
That suggests to me government money.
Morgan thinks the structures bear the
hallmarks of a secret military installation.
Judging by the age, these could be seven or
eight decades old that's dropping all of this
right into the time period of the Second
World War.
This thing is amazing. Look at this.
While much of the structure has long since
rotted away or been destroyed by hurricanes.
Clues to what drew the military into these
swamps do remain.
All down the line of these platforms.
There are iron rings.
These are gun mounts.
The fact that you've got all these gun
platforms lined up like this, it makes me
think that I might be looking at.
An anti-aircraft training center.
Declassified military records confirm that
these sinking ruins were once a secret World
War Two training base called Shell Beach.
And it played a key role in tackling a
catastrophic shortcoming in America's
defenses at the dawn of World War Two.
During World War Two, The American forces,
particularly the Navy, had this sort of sense
of invincibility.
Now, that is an image that's vastly
different to what the state of the US
military was, just as the country was
entering World War Two.
When Japanese fighters and dive bombers
devastate Pearl Harbor.
Us. Battleships are ill prepared to defend
themselves.
It's a mistake the Navy vows never to
repeat.
When we get involved in the war.
After Pearl Harbor, the US military has to
begin a crash training program to get sailors
trained up to shoot down enemy airplanes.
With Nazi U-boats and planes also threatening
America's shores.
The Navy starts transporting rookie gunners
into the Louisiana swamp to teach them the
art of anti.
Shooting across the lake would have provided
a nice field of fire.
And pilots would actually fly target planes
to be shot at.
Get practice against live targets.
40% of the recruits are volunteers, many of
them fresh from high school.
After just eight weeks, they are sent to
fight fascism in Europe.
Or to join the Pacific Fleet and experience
the hell of naval combat.
Men who trained here would ultimately be on
board ships that are fighting off waves of
Japanese suicide aircraft.
During the first few months of the war, US
anti aircraft gunners shoot down 56 enemy
planes. Within three years, they are
bringing down almost 20 times that number.
And thanks in no small part to these weird
ruins in the Louisiana bayous.
Just think about how critical this was.
I mean, in many ways it was facilities like
this that produced the final victory in the
Second World War.
The decaying World War Two facility sits just
400 yards from the larger sunken structure in
the image.
It could be a barracks for the training
center, but that doesn't make any sense.
How would you move people back and forth?
Up close, the mystery deepens.
Look at this thing. This looks like what a
castle I drew as a kid Looked like.
If we were in Europe, I'd go, That's
definitely a fort.
But we're not in Europe.
We're in Louisiana.
There are other forts on the US's southern
coastline dating from the Civil War.
But this is unlike any of them.
The forts are very low profile.
But this thing, it's just looming up out of
the marsh.
It's incredible. To really get to the bottom
of what this structure is, I'm going to have
to get on shore and walk around it.
To Morgan. The structure's medieval design is
unprecedented.
I mean, it's like a cathedral in here.
I have never seen anything like this.
This is unique. This is one of a kind.
The crumbling walls suggest the swamp fort
likely dates from the early 1800s.
The structure clearly belongs to the era
before the introduction of rifle artillery,
because in the era of rifle artillery, this
thing would not have stood a chance.
The middle of the 19th century.
Witnesses the arrival of rifled barrels.
Revolutionizing the power range and accuracy
of artillery.
Brick fortifications are replaced with low
profile concrete ones which can better
withstand the apocalyptic onslaught of this
new generation of weapons.